bonjour parce qu'elle ne veut merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
la haute autorité de santé a donné son
feu vert lundi pour la vaccination des 5
11 ans mais beaucoup de parents se
posent des questions les enfants qui ont
très peu de chances de faire des formes
graves du coc vide alors pourquoi les
parents voudrait-il faire vacciner leurs
enfants
un problème problème de liaison avec
pascal neveu on retournera voir parce
qu'elle ne veut dès qu'il sera
disponible en tous les cas la
vaccination des 5 11 ans a débuté le 15
décembre en espagne l'un des pays où on
vaccine le plus contre le coc vie de 19
ans retourne du côté de pascal neveu
bonjour à ce que vous êtes là vous oui
bonjour que vous êtes donc un
psychanalyste spécialiste des enfants je
disais tout à l'heure pascal neveu la
haute autorité de santé a donné son feu
vert lundi pour la vaccination des 5 11
ans mais beaucoup de parents se posent
des questions puisque les enfants ont
très peu de chances de faire des formes
graves du coc vide alors pourquoi les
parents voudrait-il faire vacciner leurs
enfants et les parents sont toujours
très réticents ils sont frileux parce
que ils veulent et bien évidemment
protéger leurs enfants parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu suffisamment de pédagogie
d'enseignements sur ce qu'était un arn
messagers ce cas un vaccin et et puis ce
corps aux navires us qui est assez
complexe et qui nous enquiquine depuis
pas mal de temps donc ils sont dans
dans une dualité entre j'ai envie de
protéger mon enfant je fais qu'il ya pas
de trop de de risque grave de maladie
mais ils peuvent être contagieux
également contaminé leurs parents les
grands parents les amis etc et d'un
autre côté j'ai pas envie qu'ils aient
une nouvelle dose la france est quand
même très dont il vaccin depuis des
années
d'ailleurs 62 % des parents des 5 11 ans
refusent le vaccin pour leurs enfants
selon un récent sondage bva pour orange
et pour rtl le chiffre était identique
il ya quatre mois est-ce que ça va
perdurer selon vous qu'est ce qui
explique cette réticence vous l'avez
expliqué un petit peu mais s'il n'y a
pas les effets indésirables également
bien certaines prises de parole sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya énormément de
fuites news de toute façon il ya
beaucoup de médecine parallèle également
qu'ils s'engagent contre les
vaccinations de manière générale et
c'est vrai que lorsque nous on est
vacciné moi je suis triplement vacciner
on les vacciner un pack 1 un certain âge
on se tire pas dans 10 ans 20 ans on
n'aura peut-être pas d'effets
secondaires mais c'est vrai que pour un
enfant un parent va vouloir le protéger
et va penser son avenir en se disant
mais peut-être qu'il y à des risques
futurs parce que le vaccin a été créée
de manière extrêmement rapide mais ça
c'est les nouvelles technologies qui
veut qui le permettent mais mais toutes
les études montrent très bien que on a
très tôt des fesses aux comptes et ont
malgré ce qu'on rencontre
pour l'instant on n'a quand même pas
beaucoup de recul puisque ça a été fait
assez rapidement la chaise qui a donné
son aval mais une vaccination je cite
n'est exigible ni obligatoire est-ce que
simplement le fait de prononcer ces mots
ce n'est pas justement préparer les
esprits à une future obligation mais si
à mon avis on se dirige totalement faut
pas se voiler la face et c'est vrai que
la terminologie obligatoire
et est un peu particulière elle
elle va heurter si vous voulez des
personnes qui y sont réfractaires à
toute forme d'obligations toute forme de
dictature sanitaire si je puis dire ce
sont les termes d'ailleurs qu'on entend
assez assez fréquemment néanmoins il ya
quand même un bon sens
alors ensuite et pour les personnels
soignants était temps que je vais me
mettre à dos mais nous on est tous
vaccinés depuis fort longtemps contre
l'hépatite b était alors c'est une autre
forme de deux vaccins mais cependant je
pense que il faut un effort pédagogique
qu'on explique plutôt que cinq minutes
de météo tous les soirs sur la
télévision publique mais qu'on ait des
tutoriels pour raconter ce qu est un
vaccin 1 coronavirus cette maladie ce
qu'on vit qui est très particulier et
puis ce kernel messagerie et en coin il
ya effectivement parfois des effets
secondaires mais qui sont très mineures
vous êtes psychanalyste spécialiste des
enfants dans quel état d'esprit sont les
enfants vis-à-vis de la vaccination on a
beaucoup parlé des parents parce que
pour les mineurs est-ce que c'est pas un
peu traumatisant de de se faire injecter
un produit alors ils sont ils sont à la
fois réticents mais il se rappelle avoir
reçu également d'autres vaccins celui ci
les plus particuliers en consultation
j'ai très peu de jeunes qui qui ont peur
de la peur de cela parce qu'ils y voient
que leurs parents ont été vaccinés qui a
pas eu d'effets secondaires également
mais c'est surtout la frilosité c'est la
peur des adultes et puis la peur
également parce qu'ils entendent soit
sur les réseaux sociaux soit la
télévision également qui va les rendre
dubitatif et salle la problématique
principale est pour ça que j'insiste sur
la pédagogie nécessaire auprès des
enfants et le devoir des adultes c'est
le devoir du gouvernement également les
enfants on leur a dit depuis le début de
cette pandémie mettez le masque enlevé
lé masque au début de la pandémie on
disait que les enfants ne craignent rien
vis-à-vis du comics je mets à leur place
ils n'y comprennent plus rien non
d'ailleurs nous aussi les exemples il ya
un discours qui est totalement disparate
ya un discours totalement mais
contradictoires depuis depuis le début
il n'y a pas eu un consensus en termes
de pédagogie en termes d'enseignement
et c'est là où effectivement il faut
pouvoir discuter
et transmettre auprès de nos enfants de
nos petits-enfants également ce qu'il en
est de la maladie là il y avait fait ça
va cristalliser encore davantage les
peurs il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
refusent et qui ne vont pas aller
c'était noël rappelez vous l'année
dernière on disait aux grands parents
voilà vous mettez dans une pièce à part
où il venait pas au fait pas ce qu'on
veut vous protéger le terme de principal
à mon avis et nos miniature de 2 c'est
triste c'est protéger l'autre et se
protéger soi même parce qu'un enfant il
peut être porteur il peut transmettre
alors dire ça un enfant c'est compliqué
parce que ça peut le culpabiliser
dernière est explicite et on travaille
dessus de manière à ce que effectivement
on les oblige quelques pas à se faire
vacciner est très très très compliqué
sur un plan psychique pour un enfant et
pour un adulte et pour un parent
dernière question rapidement parce
qu'elles ne veulent à la pandémie génère
beaucoup de stress est un nom que les
services de pédopsychiatrie sont
dépassés est ce que c'est votre cas dans
votre cabinet les enfants sont sont
désemparés un enfant de 5 6 ans chez le
psy c'est un peu tôt quand même non
ouais c'est un peu tôt tout dépend des
problématiques qui viennent pas
principalement pour ça mais on sait que
au niveau des hôpitaux qui écume et
cetera il ya beaucoup de consultations
par rapport à cela mais à nouveau un
enfant va être pressé si le parent est
stressé qui n'envoie pas des bons
signaux je sais que c'est pas évident ça
fait quasiment deux ans que on est face
à cette a7 coded qui est très complexe
on n'arrête pas de dire 'voilà nouvelles
doses mais non ce sont des rappels
plutôt que d'utiliser le terme et aux
nouveaux vaccins ce sont des rappels à
chaque fois c'est vrai que ça doit pas
durer non plus pendant pendant des
années il ya différents courants
certains vont prôner
si je puis dire
qu on dire ça mais je peux pas utiliser
le terme ça me faire des ennemis mais le
fait que brasser la vie était donc on
doit mourir à un moment donné et puis
d'autres au contraire on doit se monter
dit et je le comprends parfaitement la
ji doit prévaloir par rapport à cette
mort et puis et puis toutes ces images
d'incubation de réanimation et compagnie
c'est très complexe dans les services
hospitaliers actuellement pour un enfant
je pense que s'il est important c'est de
lui dire avec avec les mots ce qu'est un
virus comment il a été vacciné par
rapport à d'autres maladies
qui ne relève plus de la pandémie et
cette pandémie et les mondiale et des
pack français n'aiment pas le foot ont
rappelé aussi merci parce qu'elle ne
veut d'abord et pereiro sûr je rappelle
que vous êtes psychanalyste spécialiste
des enfants est là avec